I was one of the greatest bantamweights
of all time with his resume right now
and current fighting is just different
than back in the day so I think aljo is
the best bantamweight so me going out
there and beating him will be massive
will be huge but yeah I thought Henry
versus sugar you know Battle of the
Mexican Champs what would be interesting
but this will be good still when you
look at Henry's skill set if he fought
you the way fought aljo that kind of
weird like taekwondo like straight up
stance man boy if he gets past aljo he
fights sugar this way that's this could
be a tough night with that straight up
chin in the air style and hands yeah
that was weird I mean Connor posted a
video like what are you doing standing
like that you're 5'3 fight like it don't
fight like you're agree I mean that's
not even a way to fight even if you're
tall with your chin up like that hands
like that don't go out there making
breakdowns saying you know the greatest
coach of all time the greatest fighter
of all time they go out there with a
whack-ass dance like that he's lucky he
lost to aljo because if he didn't lose
algebra he would have lost to me in a
way worse fashion I would have put his
lights out